okey-dokey everyone
okay welcome everyone this is the
march edition of the virtual pi data
cambridge
meetup um today
we have um one speaker leandra lunas who
is going to speak to us about
tvmc a command line driver for tvm
and afterwards we have time for question
obviously
and then we are trying something new i
personally i had this idea to try out
this
um you know to somehow try to recreate
the
the atmosphere of the the the coffee
break or the pizza break that we had
during the real meet-up
uh it's it's an experiment we will see
how it works so
um i'm going to post instructions to joy
for for everyone who is interested to
join sort of like a
virtual um meeting room on
on gather dot town so so i don't know if
if anyone is as old as me you will
probably remember these uh
zelda and legends of zelda computer
games so this
the design will look very much familiar
to you so um i'm going to say a little
bit more how how this works in a few
seconds
um and also uh the meetup will be
recorded i i hope everybody's okay with
that
uh to to everyone who died in
um um you you cannot share
your video um just that's just because
this zoom
is set up but of course you know if you
read out your questions and that sort of
stuff that part will all be recorded
and of course the presentation as well
um
okay so um a quick
few words of introduction um we
are pi data cambridge we started back in
november 2018. we have been
pretty consistent with our meetups
almost every month we had a meetup since
2018 only
some few outages or exceptions
and we are usually every uh last
wednesday of the month
and and since uh covet and the pandemic
we've been
um we've been virtual as well so we
is four of us it's federico eures
leandro and myself ole
and um i should say we are all
volunteers so we are all doing this in
our
spare time okay so
um just a few words for those of you who
don't know um
what is what is pi data and and and what
do we actually do what's behind of this
so pi data is the outreach program of
num focus and num focus is a
is a non-profit organization based in
the us
that looks after and supports open
source software
um what exactly does that mean so so num
focus gives
various ways of supports to a lot of
really popular open source projects
so they are focused
on the python ecosystem of projects so a
lot of the typical python
uh analysis and and data science tools
are
un supported by num focus but it's not
only about python they have
as you can see on the slides support for
some julia packages and other languages
as well
so they are about open source they give
a lot of financial support but also sort
of like training to open source
developers
and it's in in general uh really
a very useful thing i mean this is
really sort of the the the piping and
the infrastructure that keeps a lot of
the
um data science and and also quite
frankly just the internet work running
so
um and we as a pi data meetup we are
part of the outreach program so we're
trying to sort of like
convey the the the message what numb
focus does and
and sort of present a little bit what
they are doing and
um if you think that sounds appealing
please do consider
a donation to num focus there's a link
that you can also find on their website
because we are part of the num focus
outreach program we also have a code of
conduct
it boils really down to a few common
sense
words um be kind to others
do not insult or put down others and in
generally
behave professional you know just keep
in mind that any sort of like
harassment and and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes in language are not
appropriate for pi data
if you feel that something wasn't really
going quite right and you want to
complain about something that feel that
you feel didn't follow this code of
conduct
you can first of all contact all of us
the organizers we are
on on meetup and we are on twitter but
we also have like an act
we have an external person uh that's
leonie mook
that's um our code of conduct response
person so you can
uh speak to her directly if you want to
not
discuss with the organizers
something that you felt violated the
conduct
so as promised um uh
something a little bit about gather so
this is sort of like our virtual meeting
room uh you don't need to
write down the link or take screenshots
of it i'm going to post it in in the
chat
towards the end of the meetup as well so
you can just click on that
so so um it is of course voluntary
but i would you know really encourage
everyone to to just check in briefly
um it's it's it's sort of like a virtual
meeting room where we can all get
together and we can chat
um directly through video links so
everyone will be able to share video and
share voice but if you don't want that
you can also just chat via the text
function and it's really
you know meant to be an informal way to
talk to us if you guys
want to talk about the meetup or if you
have ideas for other tools or just want
to
you know maybe touch base with leandro
and chat a little bit more to him
um then that's an option um
so we will have like a really
i i wasn't sure how many people would
join so i have like a pretty large
meeting room i
i hope people won't get lost in it um
there's also something
if you're sort of like close to a table
then you are entering a private area
and then only people that are standing
around the table will hear
and see what you are saying so your so
your video becomes
localized so if you just want to sort of
like i don't have like a chat with
someone
um then and don't want to broadcast it
to to everyone else and you can just go
to one of these tables
and um you you have to dial in using a
pc there's no no app or anything like
that and of course our code of conduct
applies to this
post meetup social as well so so you
know please be
respectful and and in general just kind
to each other
in this space um
i said already we are all volunteers um
but
um in i we do have sponsors and i just
wanted to briefly explain
what they are doing and how they are
supporting us so um our sponsoring
organizations support us in in various
ways
for instance by paying for the zoom
licenses to pay for
meetup.com actually the gather dot com
is also paid for by by num focus so all
of these organizations
support us in the in various ways and we
are we are not making any money
with that but um we um
they they support us in in other ways
so if if anything that these sponsors
are doing interests you
for instance some of the job
opportunities that i'm going to show
right now
then please if you contact these
organizations mentioned that you saw
these information or these job adverts
at python pi data cambridge that really
helps us a lot
because then these organizations have
the feedback that that
you know their their program is actually
useful um for what they are doing here
and their postings are being looked at
um so uh when it comes to arm
they are uh they have a couple of job
openings arm is a
local company based here in cambridge uk
but they have offices all over the world
um these are i think of
racks that are only based in cambridge
principal data engineering
graduate data engineering a data analyst
at the the undergraduate
level and a senior performance analysis
engineer in
machine learning so um the both
volunteers federico and leandro are
working for
arms so if if any of this interests you
i just want to learn a little bit more
what the company is doing please do
reach out to them
and they will be very happy to talk to
you um
then the raspberry pi foundation used to
be our venue sponsors so
when we were still allowed to meet up in
in real life
um they were hosting us and
and we are we are of course indebted for
that and
um if if you the raspberry pi makes
these mini computers
uh that are very popular but they have
sort of like an educational outreach
program as well
if that interests you check out their
weekly live streams there's a lot of
interesting stuff around digital making
happening there
and then um fetch ai is is also a
local company based here in cambridge um
there in general in into the the themes
around cryptocurrencies
and and uh distributed ledgers doing a
very
uh lots of very interesting stuff around
that um
they have published a new sets of
stop-loss
agents um that are
basically helping users to avoid
excessive impermanent loss
by automatically withdrawing liquidity
from uni swot and pancake swap pools
so if you're into in generally into this
topic of of
cryptocurrencies i i would encourage you
to check this out
um there's also a main
lounge of their main net coming up on
the 31st of march 2021.
so if you're that's interested you have
all the links here
uh i will also post a copy of these
slides or a link
to these slides on the meetup page
you'll find all the links here
no need to write things down and if you
think this
sounds all pretty cool and then
interesting then
um please check out there they're job
adwords as well those are two examples
they're looking for someone in in
marketing and communications
and a python developer so and and
possibly more so feel free to
reach out to them if any of this
interests you
and um last but not least we
the pi data cambridge chapter we are
always looking for speakers
and we are also looking for sponsors so
if you are
interested in giving a talk or if you're
interested in sponsoring or even both
then please get in touch with us
we are happy to talk about both of them
so um we are on twitter that's our
twitter handle
we have an email address yeah email at
pi data cambridge
uh pidatacambridge gmail.com sorry
um so so please get in touch any other
feedback is of course always welcome
and um the recordings will be published
on the
general pi data youtube channel
and so if if you want to catch up you
can look there
there are also recordings from uh
previous meetups
and um that is it in terms of
introduction
i'm going to stop here i'm going to have
a very quick look because i saw
some question in the um
q and a oh there's okay there's one one
question already i i'm going to answer
this live
if there was a certificate of
participation and so on
i'll answer this later on um and i hand
over to the envelope now leon with the
the fluoresce
okay uh yeah i'll share my screen
[Music]
are you
i i could see the slides very briefly
and then even the way
yeah let's see the slides now okay uh
yes so yes well as ollie
mentioned um my name is andrew and i
work at arm and specifically
i work in this project called tvm
and my my talk today is
about tdmc a command liner command line
driver for tvm
i would like to start
actually with an introduction
not only about tvmc but also
i appreciate that not everybody is
familiar with dvm so i will start
a brief introduction about tvm um
as this talk is being recorded i will
try to give you also some pointers if
you want to
check out more about the project and and
how it works and everything
with some links that i will uh
show during the talk and you can have a
look uh
later on now uh after this introduction
i am gonna run two demos
to illustrate the
workflow using tvmc to compile networks
using tbm and
in the end i will be happy to
answer any of your questions so please
um use the the q a box on
uh zoom to post your questions and now
uh
i'll pick them up just
after the talk now
um with in a quick introduction about
tvm and tvmc
so i'd like to just uh
say and kind of the overall relationship
between
tvm and dvmc is that tvmc
works on top of tvm to offer
some of the tvm features via
a command line interface and now this is
a good point to
give up one step back
and explain a little bit about what tbm
is
so if we go to tvm website
which is tdm.apache.org
you will be you'll be able to see this
diagram that
um illustrates um
and kind of uh overall approach on
dbm so on the top you see
all the neural network frameworks
we use so tensorflow keras
coreml onyx pytorch
that people use to create their models
create their neural networks
and the objective for those neural
networks is to run
on top of some hardware so if you see
on the bottom side of the diagram we see
hardware devices and run times
that people want their models to run
so we have cpus we have custom
accelerators gpus
dsps npus and all these devices
in which people
want to run their models so what tvm
does is the and the main
reason why tdm exists is to bridge the
gap
between many different input network
formats created in many different
frameworks
to be run on hardwares that want to be
supported by
many frameworks so on one side many
models
that we want to run on different devices
and for that tvm bridge
those different worlds to
make the models portable cordless
devices
and make the devices to support many
input formats
now there are many ways
we can use tvm so tvm offers
a python api that you can use
to run your models and compile your
models and
make some model create created on
one of these frameworks to run on these
target devices
you can also use the c plus plus api
in which you write your c plus plus
program
to accomplish that using tvm apis
so now the idea with tvmc
is to offer those user-facing features
that people want to use tvm exposed
as a tool so tvmc will get those
uh main features that they
that will accomplish tasks that users
want
like compilation i want to get my model
and generate
a tdm compiled model so that i can run
on my device
uh and uh on a different moment
uh i want to get this compiled model
and run on the device so these are the
sorts of
features that uh if we look
at tvm as a as a
main framework uh tvmc will get some of
these features
and expose those to users in a
simple command line interface now to
switch back
to my slides uh then
this raises the question of um
why do we need a command line driver on
a framework that offers
many many features already so
there are three main reasons that we see
for that
in and the the most important one
is that for people who are interested in
deploying their models
and to getting those models and make
them do something on actual hardware
and want to use tvm they
not always are are interested in all
these underlying
layers of the compiler and the
frameworks and internal apis
that you need to know to use dvm
in c plus plus or python for that
matter the second one is to
get a unified and documented interface
so
means basically
self-contained help options that you can
use
to understand what is available to you
on that
tool and the third one is that
if you start using tvm for many models
you see that some of the
boilerplate codes that you need to run
are very similar
and what we basically did was to
consolidate those sources
that are that use kind of
good practices on tvm site to expose
those features
so you don't need to create boilerplates
over and over for each model that you
want to run
now tvmc
is part of tbm so if you
install tvm as a python package you
already have tbmc and
once you install it you have
tvmc as a command line i will
just quickly demonstrate that on my
[Music]
terminal here so in this terminal i
have a tvm
built and installed and
to do that i can at this point
tell you that there is this docs page
on tvm website and you see that is
installation and then you can follow
this guide in order to have a
working tvm installation on your machine
now once we have this we can
basically going back to the terminal
just type
tvmc and
we'll be able to uh use the tool on top
of tvm so we can see already that there
are some options there are some commands
that you can run
always documented in the command line
interface
so um
as i mentioned major features are
exposed as
subcommands there are three subcommands
at the moment
the first one is tvmc compile that we
use to compile models from
the supported frameworks
we have tvmc run also that allows us to
run the model use compiled
using tvmc compile and generate
predictions
and we also have dbmc tune that allow us
to
perform tuning which is a way
that tvm offers some features
for us to do
improvements on the model for
this to run with better performance on a
given
target device
so on tvmc compile
what we have is uh the input is a model
that we create on one of the supported
frameworks
so the supported frameworks at the
moment are keras onyx pythons tensorflow
and tf lite
this space here
and what we um what we can do
is to use tvm to compile that model for
a given target device
so uh some of these devices
for example if you are compiling it to
run
on uh on a device
that doesn't have native compilation
tools for it
you can also use tvmc to cross-compile
it to a
to a target device so if tvm uh is not
supported on that
on that specific device you can cross
compile it
on a different machine so you have a
model that
can just run on that target machine
and there's a high level view of that
what we have is the input model
then we run tbmc compile and what we get
as an output
is a tvm compiled module
now the next sub command
is tvmc run so in tvmc run
what we the the main feature we are
exposing from tvm
is the ability to get a compiled module
and produce uh predictions of it
so we have the compiled module we give
it some inputs
and then we generate predictions
um another important use of tbmc
run is that we can generate the
profiling data
so we can see for our model each layer
of our model how much of the time spent
on running that model
is each of its
layers consuming so we'll see an one
example of that
very soon so the other important thing
is that uh sometimes if we want to run
and tvm
to run this comp tvm compiled module on
a remote machine
we can use something that is uh
exposed by tvm which is called an rpc
tracker
so that we can from our machine to
remote execute
on a different machine
so as a again as a high level what we
have is
we have the compiled module from
previous step
we provide it with some input tensors
tbmc run and we generate the output
tensors for us to
check or to interpret somehow
i'll show you an example of that
later on the third one is the tbmc tune
so tbmc tune exposes the
tuning facilities of tvm so the
tuning process aims to do some
performance improvements by finding
better configuration parameters
so as in shape sizes for example
uh it's something that can be tweaked by
tdmc2
the output of a tuning session in
tvm this is kind of more like tvm jargon
the tv the output of a tuning session is
a file in json format
that contains
network using these configurations the
performance
in terms of time is
this so it can use this data to perform
kind of an um optimization loop
and and try to find better parameters
for your network
um the tuning uh can take
uh quite a long time so and for that
reason
uh for this talk i prepared i have an
example
of the outputs uh and i will point you
to some
uh other resources in in which you can
check
and read more about tuning uh in this
context
now as a high level view we have
for tuning we have the input model
and then we run tvmc tune on it
and then what we get as an output is
tuning logs which is that
json file that correlates
operators parameters and
time results
now one thing when when
implementing such a generic tool like
tbmc
uh one thing that is important to
realize is that
every different model can be very
particular in terms of
input shapes and output shapes so
if we are dealing with images for
example for cnns
we will need to understand whether that
what's the format of the tensors for
that particular network for that
particular framework
for example and it's the same for the
output so
what does a set of outputs really mean
in terms of
human readable information so are these
classes and what does these classes
class numbers mean for example
so for that reason
in tdmc we use the npset format
so np set format is you can read it as a
serialized numpy arrays which
in very simple terms means getting that
object that is an array and writing that
to a file
so in that way we can provide
actually a generic tool but
it requires from us to
pre-process inputs that will go to the
model
and also to post process the outputs of
that model
in order to extract information that is
relevant to us
so it means basically that
before running if if we want to generate
results for
our model using tvmc run we need to
pre-process the inputs to generate an
npx file that is
accepted in the right shapes by that
model
whereas in the outputs we also need to
do some post processing to
if we want to read the information that
those output tensors are giving us
this format is very well documented you
can read about it on the
numpy website and i will show an example
of a fully working example of how this
pre-processing and post-processing
thing uh works uh
yes so exporting into npz format can be
done in
a few lines of code using numpy i will i
will show an example of that
now uh
[Music]
this was the introduction of the of the
of tvm which is this
uh framework that bridges uh
frameworks as in tensorflow by torch
onyx and others
with hardware devices and in particular
also with uh neural network accelerators
so
uh if if you are on the um
on the side that is implementing your
models you are interested into
in this model to run as many devices as
possible
if you are a device vendor
you also want to to have good coverage
in terms of input frameworks
so tvm is that bridge to to
connect those different worlds
now uh now i'll start with the practical
sessions and the
and there will be two practical sessions
in this
talk uh the first one i will show you
how to compile and run a model
using tvmc so for that
um just to summarize what
what we want to achieve with that so we
want to run a
simple workflow using tvmc from the
model
to predictions in our local machine
so we also for to do that we will
use tvmc compile we start from our input
model
and generate something that runs on our
machine
and then we would have that discussion
about
pre-processing and post processing of
inputs and outputs
to be able to check whether
these outputs that my model generated
really represent
what i want to read from that model
um yes so uh there are
some documentation about that official
documentation on tvm
uh if you want to have a look there is a
tutorial called
getting started with tvm command line
driver
and we'll show most of what i'm going to
demonstrate here
in practice so have a look on that one
if you
if you want to read more about that
now the model we are going to use is the
resnet 50 model
which is a model used to classify
images um and to compile the model we
will basically run tvmc compile
we'll give it a target and then the
model
and we get as an output is a tvm
compiled model
so just switch to my terminal just
clean up i uh pre-downloaded
uh the resnet model it is here
and what i'm gonna do is to run tvmc
compile target eq
llvm uh i will explain this llvm in a
sec
and then we have as the final argument
the
model here so
while it uh compiles it takes a few
seconds
and uh i've explained this llvm
uh target llvm for you so
in this command line what tvm will do
it will use tv it will use llvm
which is a compiler framework
if you're not aware to generate code
that will target the local machine
so in practice it will compile this
as a native library that represents that
model
so each operator on that model will be
sent to llvm that will generate
code that runs on the local machine and
we can
actually uh look into that uh code if we
say
uh dash dash dump code
ll we can see that intermediate language
that was generated
that represents native code
that will be used to run our model
so just take a moment
so these are some messages the messages
you see
are some messages coming from tvm that
uh
we'll see that it doesn't have a
specific configuration for specific
um operators on this
uh and then we use default
implementations that that's
all now uh we have this
module.tar this one
which is our compiled uh compiled model
and we have also as we sent that dash
dump code
we have the lrvm representation which is
the low level representation
for that particular model if we look
into it
we will see that this is
llvm
language what is it
so for each of the uh
operators it will have an implementation
that will translate in the local machine
to native code
okay so that's part one we start from
our onyx model which is this one and we
generate a compiled model
that is the compiled model
model.tar now
the second part we want to use this
resnet module to identify an image
and switching back to these lights
what we want to do is to use tvmc
now tbmc run to input that
input something to that model and then
collect
the outputs so the way that we're gonna
do it
is to run tbmc run we will input some
uh some tensors
and then we will get as an output
tensor from the model that we will then
interpret
so that's basically we'll pass
this image and we want to see
later on which predictions this
model generated
now switching to the to the terminal
what we want to do so now comes the time
that we discussed
about input preprocessing and post
processing
now if we see i crea i pre-created here
this
uh resnet inputs which is a
pre-processing
script so for if your model is dealing
for example with sound
you need to do different pre-processing
if your model
is doing some other classification on
images or is reducing blur or
something different you need a different
pre-processing script
that matches the specific tensors your
model expects so if we see this this is
a very simple
uh script that uses numpy and pill to
download an image so it uses some
utilities from tvm but that's that's not
mandatory
so it will download an image resize to
the size that the model expects
uh set the transpose the
the array the way the model expects
apply this which is normal
normal process if you are dealing with
any
imagenet related network so it does some
normalization
and then the i mean the only thing here
that
is required by uh tdmc
is this line here that's the numpy
saves that with some name and then
it will save those tensors
on a file so for any other
model that you wanted to connect using
resnet
you would need to do some sort of
normalization
and the only thing we have on tdmc is
that
we expect it to be on an npz file
now this is basically what this script
does this is the
preprocessing that is needed so what i'm
gonna do
i i'm gonna execute this resnet
input and it will uh
yeah so the file was was pre-downloaded
because i i did i
prepared it before but basically
downloaded that image
and created that cut dot
so what we are going to do is to do tbmc
run
dash dash input so we
we will redirect the
outputs to something called
predictions.nbc which is
basically the is a way that tvmc
will do the same similar process with
the outputs
and serialize to file and then we'll say
which model we want and this of course
the model we
compiled before so
running it uh is quite fast
when compared to compiling it because it
will just get the model
and run with the input tensors to
generate the
outputs and um
what we need to do now is to validate
the output
so there are some tensors in that um
in that file and what we want to do is
to
check what they mean so to do that
i created this script which is called
resnet output that's the same if you get
a resnet outputs anywhere
you will need to do something similar to
this so
basically it downloads a list of labels
which will translate
each class to a valuable
to a value that we can read so a value
that's
meaningful to us rather than having a
given code and coded value
it will say this encoded value means dog
this encoded value means chair this
encoded value means
cut and and all these classes
that are imagenet classes
uh then it will it will read the file
read
predictions predictions.npz which is the
file we produced and we'll correlate
both
so after it correlates both uh
it will print the five
more uh the five kind of stronger
classes the
five um highly uh
scored classes in that output
so uh you can see also that that resnet
50 doesn't
offer this soft max which is
a way to calibrate the outputs and
translate those output tensors uh
to be linked to labels
and that's something we are doing also
in the script so it's very small script
again if your model deal with voice
if your model deal with uh
different types of inputs sensors
and all these things you will need a
different post processing script to
extract that information from the model
to something that you can read
so what we expect when running this is
for this print
to print a class with a given
a code with a given name
and then the probability with a given
number
so that's what we are going to do so
we will use this predictions.npz which
is the file we generated
so we just do python resnet
output and then for that particular
image that we downloaded that i had on
my slide
it's it classifies it as a tubby cat
tiger hat tiger and and
so and so on so very strong this one's
this one radiator not very strong
but that these are the five most more
or highly
scored classes in this particular model
for this particular
input okay so this
is basically us validating the output of
our script
um and then well just to
uh wrap up this demo
we compile the model we deal with inputs
and
outputs and then we generate meaningful
uh information that we can read
but that's basically to validate the
model
if we if we are
using this this tool to generate
predictions is basically for our own uh
consumption
now the second one very quick is uh
regarding profiling and tuning
so as i mentioned we want to collect
very often we want to collect
performance information
from our models and to do that
we basically
run the same tvmc run we just add
profile to this
um let's uh yeah just takes a few
seconds
so it generates with some other debug
information and things
but the important bit is this table here
so there is this
node name uh operations
and time uh and other information about
that particular layer
so we can see that how the time is
spent on each layer of our model and
how sometimes tvm can get
two or more different operators and fuse
those operators
into some custom
operators to be used on our network and
then we can see how time
is being spent on each one of those
so this is useful in case we are looking
for bottlenecks in the model
and these sorts of things we can
evaluate all this information
when generated via tvm and dvmc
using those parameters
now there is also um
so to enable that we run with the
dash dash profile and the
as i mentioned the tuning basically we
run
tdmc tune in a given model and we'll
generate
some tuning logs or tuning records which
is the official name
for that particular model i have one
example here
um that i generated before
so it's this file here tuning record so
if we go to two new records
you see is more like out of curiosity
just to show that this will
basically generate lots of data
with different
configurations for operators and
results that we can then use
to improve performance on our model
so that's uh basically the way
this works you run tvmc tune and then we
use
the tuning logs for two reasons you can
use the tuning logs
to do uh more tuning and start
uh with some point that we already run
and we can also use the tuning records
to
compile the model which is which is then
go
just switch back to the slides
now
uh yes so using the 20 logs we can use
on tbmc compiler which is then go so
tbmc compile we passed
tuning logs with those specific plugs
uh and we can also use them for further
training if we pass tuning logs to the
tbmc
tune command
now to wrap up the talk
uh we discussed about tdmc
which is a command line tool for tvm
i briefly introduced tvm
starting from its main goal
which is to bridge frameworks
and hardware platforms
we covered compilation
and tuning models so i didn't cover
cross compilation in this one
but i can give you a link to that which
i'm going to do in a moment
we discussed obviously the need for
input
pre and post processing of inputs and
outputs
that's a requirement from the models as
we are trying to provide
a generic tool with tmc
uh and also wanted to
say that tvmc is under active
development at the moment
so lots of new features
in discussion and coming in
soon we use o
is implemented in on github so
tvm's github is apache slash tvm
uh you can see prs you
would be very happy if you go there to
report bugs
suggest new features either on github or
on the disqus
platform so i'm just
gonna show you something before
to finish so there is this website
which is called tvmconf.org which is the
last year's tvm conference
which happened december last year
and i went i just wanted to point to
the very long list of recorded talks
that you can watch
so basically covering tvm
back to back uh there are there is a
tutorials day
basically here you can even watch a
tutorial on tvmc
which is a an expanded version
of this talk so if you got interested
i will learn more so there is this
resource which is very good tvm conf.org
and i guess with
that i
can finish
and take happy to answer any questions
you might have
hey thank you very much leon very nice
talk um i have two questions in the q a
for you
um can you see it right them right now
or do you want me to read it out
i can i can see them yeah okay so um
[Music]
so the first one uh it says is tune
independent on particular back-ends or
is it portable
due to the minimal uh portable runtimes
so it's always important
that tuning is done on the
same platform that you want to run
so uh and the main reason for that is
that
the minimal uh portable runtimes that
you mentioned
in the question it varies
in different platforms for example if
you had
if you have a particular npu
device with a neural network accelerator
device
you might benefit from
some optimizations that can be done and
some
operator fusion that can be done on that
particular device that doesn't apply to
other devices like for example uh gpus
that might be uh that have offer
more parallelism or diff or
benefit from specific shapes and and
these sorts of things so
more objectively yes
tuning is dependent on on backhands
and is very important that you run
tuning
um on the if
if possible on the specific
target device that you want to optimize
for
now um second one
is can you give a sense of performance
gains of compiling using tvm versus
just using the frameworks own method
of running on traditional hardware
not something is esteric like a dsp
so there are some benefits
you can get from
translating it to native code
[Music]
there is a i don't have the numbers on
top of my mind
but there is um i'll try to paste
on the a link to a blog post that
exemplify
some of these uh comparisons
then uh performance gains uh
here i guess they mean uh time
and uh yes so
basically the benefit you get of getting
native code
rather than going through a runtime
or some specific runtime
uh provided by the framework yeah i'll
try to paste a link about that one
cool thank you very much leandro
um were there are there any more
questions
please use the chat or the q a function
okay if if there are no more questions
then
i i have a very quick one for liandro
lianvo you said very little
about yourself and what your involvement
with the tvm project
is do do you want to say
uh what you're doing for tvm or what's
your first one
yes so uh yes so i um
as i said i work at arm and we have a
team
that works on tvm in the kind of all
aspects of tvm
and my my specific involvement at the
moment
is to maintain
and try to help on tvmc
side i also have some contributions on
input frameworks like
keras for example
yeah that's that's mainly what what i'm
doing at the moment
in the project cool
sounds very interesting
okay everyone then if there are no more
questions
i'm going to stop the recording